what up guys it's not morning and
I don't have coffee
but welcome to morning coffee thoughts
it's your girl pearl
back at it with another video
um okay I want to give you my intro but
I like can't even focus right now
because
basically I want to document like the
come up and that's kind of why I like
make these videos as they're gross I can
like look back and be like oh I remember
that
um today
for the first time in my life I was
actually scared and I've never really
had I put it I've been like [ __ ] scared
where I know I'm just freaking out over
nothing you know what I mean
but today I
I am
I did some public interviews in this
town called shortage right
and
I put the link
and that's like a party place in London
and basically like
and basically I wanted to get just like
people you know that wanted to talk and
usually when they're drinking like they
want to talk more and then I want to
interview them about like abortion
versus Wade I didn't really
I wasn't even trying to talk about
abortion I was trying to talk about the
financial abortion versus uh
foreign
like women have the right to choose but
men don't have the right to choose
and have a financial abortion and I end
up like these three guys that end up
like debating for a hot minute right
um we're just like talking in circles
and I'm just like okay I need to move on
to the next people like I'm talking to
you for so long
so I I keep trying to get interviews and
these men are like
sitting around like telling everybody
that oh she's interviewing you about
abortion she said when that wasn't even
my original
it wasn't even
like what I wanted to interview people
about I wanted to focus on financial
abortion but
so
the and then like I can see them all
like talking [ __ ] right I I don't care I
don't know these people from Adam but
I I it's like almost like a mob starts
forming and it's not like a
foreign
but I just see it like I have this
foresight where I'm like oh no they're
talking there they're gonna keep getting
people and they're gonna start stopping
and they're gonna be watching and then
I'm trying to interview this last girl
and I actually really want to interview
her she seemed actually pretty mad and
like which is great those are great
people to interview because
like like I didn't get how I put it like
people that want to debate like she
seemed like she was ready to bait so I
was like this is gonna be a good
interview
but these drunk people just started like
getting really close to my camera and I
I just see these groups of people like
starting to form around me and nothing
happened to the point
like nobody attacked me nobody tried to
steal my camera but I have never been
like
that scared
in my life like honestly because I just
could see it I was like these guys are
gonna keep telling every person that
comes by that I'm pro-life and like it's
just gonna keep which is like a beta ass
move beta ass move but whatever
foreign
I don't know I I'm not to the point
where I'm big enough
that people recognize me that often I'd
say like occasionally and more when I'm
in the U.S but like I don't really get
recognized like that but
it's kind of like I'm seeing the
trade-off
where like I actually have to be worried
about my safety when I do these
interviews
and
I'm really grateful for it because I
genuinely feel like this is what I'm
meant to do I've always felt like my
calling is to talk to women like for
years I don't know why I've just always
felt like I could talk to women in a way
that like men can't and
we'll just get them to see like
different sides of an argument
but
you know it comes at a trade-off and I'm
just like realizing I like I'm just so
shook up shook because I've just never
I've always felt safe like in my life
I've never felt like I was in any danger
for the most part
um
um
I don't know wow
so
yeah that's the morning if you hear my
dog in the background she's drinking
Ellie
you're ruining my um whatever but
Ali
oh well she's not but the point is the
point is that
everything comes at a price and I know
this is going to be the price
and I've been really lucky where the
past couple of months I've never really
like everyone's been really great that
I've had on the show nobody's ever been
super hostile
the worst part I've had is someone being
mad about going viral but like whatever
so
yeah that was really scary
and I it's weird though because part of
me
I don't know I just I just genuinely
know this is what I'm supposed to do and
this is what I'm meant to be doing and
like I I feel so strongly about it like
I feel like God called me to do this
like I feel like everything in my life
up to this point like made sense
like
said like a million times today but
every everything in my life up to this
point that I've gone through and I've
done has made sense because I've just
had this calling in me that I felt like
I needed to talk to women since I was so
young and I I've just felt like from a
young age I knew that I was gonna have
some sort of platform and
I didn't know what it was with or like
how about
everything's just making sense now
but I know that soon my life is going to
be different and I can't go back
and now and it's almost like at that
point so I don't I don't know if this
made sense I'm kind of frazzled so I
don't
know if this coffee thought even is
you know
making sense but let me know in the
comments I can't even
do a okay an outro right now let me know
in the comments what you think like the
video subscribe I'll talk to you later